[Música]
eu vou ficar aqui aguardando um tempinho
meu nome está rodando aqui a produção
tem tempo é beleza
alguém se habilita a av
por favor você aqui na frente foi o
primeiro a se colocar à disposição
pode ser por aqui que a vontade
muito obrigada
como é que se chama mateus mateus onde
pediu um favor
aqui dentro de uma caixa preta ninguém
sabe quem está aqui dentro né
nem eu sei que vou te pedir um favor se
retira para mim o que está aqui dentro
esse material mesmo sem você saber não
pode tirar daí mostra por favor pode
sair muito obrigado é seu
pois então por que vocês não vieram
quando eu chamei vocês acabaram de
perder 20 reais
poderia ter comprado pode queijo café de
fora pois então o medo ea incerteza
predominou na gente mesmo quando a gente
sabe o que pode acontecer
vocês poderiam ter tropeçado na cadeira
poderiam até pagar um mico qualquer é se
colocar aqui à disposição
é complicado né o que se passa na nossa
cabeça
o que te move medo incerteza
presente o futuro pois então somos nós
jovens somos é como nós sentimos nós
temos medos medo do futuro
medo do que pode acontecer agora
prejudica prejudica a nosso futuro e
início a gente tem que tomar uma atitude
néné eu meu nome' tarde e nisso eu não
viria aqui no palco assim como a maioria
de vocês por medo incerteza e o que
acontece a partir do momento que nós
somos estimulados a fazer acontecer
nosso corpo começa a ge isso começa em
estresse e meu corpo ele entre estresse
como se fosse um leão não se tivesse
vários predadores ao meu redor
então independente do tamanho do porte
eu vou ter três leões correndo atrás de
mim e assim é como funciona a partir
desse momento é que houve essa formação
dos leões
meu interior surgiu uma do um sofrimento
físico e mental
esse sofrimento essa dor
demorou-se de diagnosticada ela até
então muitos médicos em que é falado que
não tinha nada fez para os exames
baterias de exames
tudo normal é a partir daí podia
diagnosticado como tendo a fibromialgia
biologia só quem tem sabe como é que
funciona a fibromialgia
para vocês terem uma ideia é ela fez com
que a lady gaga no rock in rio não se
apresentasse
ela deixou milhões de pessoas nas mãos
a fibromialgia é nada mais é que uma um
acúmulo de ácido lático que é aquela dor
de pós academia quando você malha muita
crônica ou seja ela não melhora o que
acontece
quando não melhora da criança na
sociedade a sociedade gera medo não vai
entrar nenhum poço imposto sem fundo
essa caixa-preta que eu coloquei seria
como se fosse nosso futuro nós jovens um
futuro incerto
a gente não sabe né
devemos correr atrás desse futuro pra
ver o que é que nos encontros pelo fato
disso de ter desenvolvido a fibromialgia
eu comecei a criar uma outra perspectiva
de vida porque cheguei a fazer várias
terapias medicamentosas psiquiátricas e
psicológicas
é a cultura e nada nada
daí eu comecei a pensar na dor
vale ressaltar também que desde o
colégio eu tive eu tive várias
incertezas quanto à minha profissão né
assim como a maioria dos jovens é muito
difícil escolher o que vai fazer no
futuro
eu sou muito grato a deus por ter
escolhido a profissão certa desde o
início do ano metade eu tenho 21 anos e
essa perspectiva de vida do meu futuro
essa certeza
começou me dá anseio começou a me dá
força mas só me dá vontade de viver
a perspectiva de vida a partir daí nós
perguntamos né
o que nós sabemos dos outros eu tô aqui
se uma pessoa extremamente normal mas eu
vivo da seguinte forma um peso que é
apelo ao g1
é como se o peso fosse distribuída no
meu organismo principalmente no meu
braço é uma obra na minha mão que o ato
né na odontologia no meio dos meus
pacientes e em por incrível que pareça
na hora que eu atendo essa do ela é
controlada pelo fato da nossa mente
controlar né
nosso organismo é muito inteligente
inclui as cargas então ele distribui a
carga emocional e física justamente para
não sobrecarregar a partir daí eu
comecei a me aceitar
aceitei a dor revolução porque não é
fácil você aceitar um peso que você
carrega todos os dias
a partir disso eu comecei a viver a
liberdade nos dá força e traz leveza e
um cinto essa leveza na hora que eu
tinha um peso do organismo
o que nós sabemos dos outros
nós jovens vivemos uma era totalmente
diferenciada a era digital
uma era que como se existisse um mundo
paralelo
o que nós sabemos dos outros o que não
sabemos os outros que estão nos outros
perfis do facebook instagram twitter a
respeito
a primeira coisa que deve fazer
no meio disso né dessa era digital a
gente estudos começaram a pesquisar o
dano que foi causado nosso psicológico
esse estresse emocional era positivo era
negativa a tecnologia estava entrando ea
gente tem que saber aproveitá lá e tem
estudos que comprovam que após 10
minutos olhando feed do instagram causa
uma depressão no sistema nervoso central
pois então a era digital ver com o fundo
e eu resolvi investir no meu futuro
investir na minha profissão um investir
na minha missão de vida aqui na terra
a tecnologia me proporcionou um melhor
planejamento
o melhor é melhor conduta técnica aos
meus pacientes proporcionar uma melhor
antle de divisão e conhecimento do ser
humano
nós dentistas nós seres humanos
não lidamos com dentes ou pessoal ou
seres sobrenaturais nós lidamos com
pessoas isso os com almas e essas almas
são questionáveis são duvidosos ninguém
sabe o que está por trás e muitas vezes
vão ter aqueles que vão te phraya que
vão tentar puxar para trás
eu sempre fui a puxou e descobrir a
verdade é que uma das minhas paixões
ensinar
aprendi na faculdade ea partir do
segundo período que foi quando comecei a
monitoria se que foi me dando maior
perspectiva ensinar passado mas melhor
da melhor forma possível o conhecimento
para os outros é função foi monitor de
anatomia cabeça pessoas durante três
anos é de oclusão radiologia periodontia
são disciplinas básicas para você tratar
o paciente utilizado uma deontologia
diga diga perdão ea partir daí nós vamos
fazendo escolhas e vão sempre existir
aqueles que vão de frei a sonhar
isso é o que devemos fazer não pare som
em você com 50 70 80 sonho
a vida continua a vida continua
no meio disso
escutamos vários comentários escutamos
comentários daqueles você também muito
novo não fazer esse curso não ou até
mesmo aquelas pessoas que falam é você
tá indo contra as irregularidades saindo
contra a maré
só que não né tem muitas vezes que bateu
o pé e falar que é isso que eu quero é
isso que eu vou cansar e corremos atrás
sempre não é sorte
tudo vem de um trabalho duro acordar
disse
isso saí da faculdade já 7 não é fácil e
devemos sempre honrar o nosso trabalho
lutar lutar é algo que dentro da nossa
cabeça ea partir daí disso começamos a
fazer é revoluções na faculdade
principalmente aqui na puc onde foi que
onde eu criei junto como é que
sensacional a primeira liga acadêmica de
odontologia ea partir daí surgiram
várias outras
[Música]
conseqüentemente a gente consegue mudar
o nosso futuro da profissão
conseguimos mudar a dignidade
conseguimos mudar a eficácia dos
tratamentos e o mais incrível é que
surgiu e feitos em outras áreas da
graduação como na biologia nas ciências
biológicas onde foi criada a primeira
liga de neuroanatomia grato muito
estou muito grato e a partir daí surge o
sorriso invisível da primeira liga
acadêmica aqui não aqui eu sou isso é
visível um projeto foi criado em 2008 o
projeto em belo horizonte onde nós
atendíamos de moradores de ruas levando
kits de higienização gênia oral agente
orientava os pacientes levava o cobertor
e o melhor era que a gente olhava o
paciente por um complexo como ser humano
e e se ele tinha essa necessidade de
rápida de tratamento e muitos desses
moradores de rua por ter um psicológico
afetada
eles desenvolviam uma anomalia ele se
desenvolve um tipo de câncer também e
daí a gente caminhava para cá pouco para
iniciar o tratamento
obrigado o que por termos apoiado desde
o início
portanto devemos valorizar a valorizar a
vida valor já o que nós temos que
valorizar nossa família que poucas vezes
é difícil falar o time mas eu te amo
e aí a gente vai ter resultados clínicos
e de maneiras excelentes s por exemplo
uma cirurgia plástica periodontal a
gente vem se investindo nessa tecnologia
digital
essa reabilitação no paciente também
carente de maneira extremamente natural
inovadora
daí a gente busca sempre resolver
resolver a palavra chave
todos nós cada um na sua profissão no
seu trabalho na sua vida pessoal
é isso que nós buscamos resolver nossos
problemas né problemas sempre vão
existir
a gente não tem escape ea partir daí
resolver nossos problemas nós começamos
a desenvolver habilidades e essas
habilidades são o que nos faz evoluir e
nós temos que estar dispostos a essa
situação
sorriso visível e invisível não só para
eles nos moradores de ruas que não tem
aparato mas pra gente que também
desconhece a realidade no sorriso
invisível um caso um show com muito ou
extremamente marcante pra mim um
ex-morador de rua extremamente simpático
ele tinha uma higienização oral boa
ele também ele tinha uma perspectiva de
vida ou em relação aos demais
e adivinha qual era a principal queixa
dele estética estética era a principal
queixa dele
ele tinha medo ele tinha receio de
chegar na casa dele deparar com a filha
dele sem um dente da frente
isso choca o jogo muito né é triste
saber que ainda acontece às essas
situações do nosso país e nós jovens
temos possível e temos capacidade e nós
temos força para mudar essa situação
portanto viva contagia energia positiva
contagiá alegria felicidade falhou eu te
amo o mais difícil que seja se não for
por palavras fala dentro do seu coração
valorize a sua vida e valorize todo sua
saúde física e mental
muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]